this right here is the ThighMaster of
urban public policy municipal
politicians all across the country have
convinced themselves that this costly
clunky hardware can somehow revitalize
their flabby downtown economies and the
streetcar fad has now infected America's
capital city in 2009 the DC government
started building a two mile streetcar
line on each street a rapidly
gentrifying neighborhood that's this
area's closest approximation of Brooklyn
this is how it was sold to the public
the modern environmentally-friendly
transportation option designed to
connect our district neighborhoods after
half a decade in development the
streetcar finally started going on test
runs and those TED talk ready
projections have collided headfirst with
the concrete realities of modern urban
life 200 million dollar dilemma the
ill-conceived aside so close two parked
cars has led to numerous accidents
there's not enough space for big trucks
to park
they'll make our job a lot harder we saw
a street car that was stopped because
the operator had to ask a legally parked
driver to fold the side mirror a
hundred-year-old technology it might
have been state-of-the-art 1915 the
streetcar had to sit and wait for almost
30 minutes meanwhile a metro bus and
several cabs could keep on moving you
can walk faster in the streetcar can
take the streetcar projects problems
have been greatly compounded by the
effective incubator of human
incompetence that is DC's Department of
Transportation which is properly set and
then exceeded dozens of deadlines will
it ever open to passengers
thought you can do so about half of the
cars in the DC system were sourced from
an American company called United
streetcar that firm sprung Athena like
from the forehead of this man Ray LaHood
who served as the Federal Secretary of
Transportation for the Obama
administration streetcars are really the
next generation of transportation for
America hood doled out about half a
billion dollars in federal funding for
about a dozen City streetcar projects
the m1 rail project could literally move
the city in the right direction this can
become a model for the rest of the
country United streetcar was the
glittering crown jewel of these efforts
and until its story we head west
portland is home to one of the biggest
streetcar systems in the country so it's
local congressman proved to be natural
allies in the hoods attempt to create
from nothing but federal largess and
breathless speechifying what would be
the first American streetcar
manufacturer in 50 years I was able to
put in weather things they call it your
mark not all your marks a bad back most
are meritorious gave the city of
Portland four million dollars for a
major America streetcar
within a very short period of time we'll
be exporting people talk about the
vision thing this is it this is the
definition of the vision system would
you like to guess how this turned out
United streetcar is now in hibernation
with no requests out there right now
this probably is a good business
decision to kind of put that on hold
United streetcar sold to just three
cities and then died from lack of demand
but streetcars aren't just a case of
colossal government waste driven by
grandstanding politicians desperate to
erect throbbing monuments to their
in-lane leadership there's also a sick
kicker many metro areas have cut their
bus service when they put in rail
service to pay for those cost overruns
they end up raising bus fares and
cutting bus service several cities
including Dallas and Los Angeles cut
back on their bus lines after installing
light rail here in the Capitol the most
recent budget from local transportation
officials ended some routes in trimmed
hours of operations for others and the
effects of that cost shifting split
along clear demographic dimensions which
I don't know might be evident between DC
streetcars core enthusiasts it'll be
nice to be able to get my friends from
Northwest to come over here once in a
while I think they're doing good I work
right there I see him passing by every
day I just waiting for him to open and
detractors a horrible decision and I
think it's just a waste of money got
buses you got cabs got bicycles it's
really unnecessary let's get it correct
when DC streetcar does finally open up
early mobile gentrify errs will have
been gifted a charmingly retro
transportation option at the same time
the streetcar will be sucking in
resources that would have been much
better spent boosting genuinely useful
but certainly less sexy transportation
programs like buses I don't know if we
just for the white folks and I'm not
being prejudiced
it's just that what is it good for
hey what y'all